Electron microscopy has been a gold standard for this kind of ultra
structure that has really defined how cells are comprised.
But it's only recently that we've been able to use
electron microscopy in a new way to look at
three dimensionality of whole cellular
systems.
The conventional electron microscopy requires you to slice through your
specimen in order to be able to hit your
electrons,
to penetrate deep enough to get an image. So you can't
using conventional transmission electron microscopy--
it's very hard to get a whole cell
visualized.
In fact,
we really don't know what a whole cell looks like, reconstructed
at the electron micrograph level.
So there's a technology that is super exciting now that's
able to potentially do that,
and it's called focused ion beam scanning electron microscopy, and the
short term for that is FIB-SEM, FIB-- focused ion beam,
and SEM-- scanning electron microscopy.
So this approach combines the power of
electron microscopy with an ability to slice through
your cell, or your specimen of interest.
And the slicing can be done down to four nanometers
or less.
So you're imaging at four-- you essentially use your scanning electron
microscope to image through your specimen
and typically the electrons will go a depth of
about four nanometers,
and then you just shave off, using your focused ion beam, to mill,
it's essentially,
it's just buzzing off the top of that cell that you've just imaged.
And then you do another image four nanometer deep,
and then you use your focused ion beam to essentially saw off that
portion.
And you just do this until you go through the entire cell.
At four nanometer slices,
if you slice through a whole cell, that's 40 microns,
it's a lot of slices.
So there are some challenges to putting all of the
information together. A, each slice you need
to analyze what you're seeing in each one of those slices,
and then you have to stitch together all of the
structures that you have outlined at each slice into one
huge volume.
This is a hugely exciting world in this field,
because to be able to segment
structures of interest in each slice requires a lot of either
machine learning or painstaking hours for an individual to
segment a particular structure of interest that you're seeing in that slice.
But you got to do that thousands and thousands of times.
So it's pretty much not possible for a human to do this,
but machines should be able to do it.
In fact,
we know that they can do it for simple structures.
The challenge is can we essentially engineer
these computers so that they can pick up some very fine structures,
that we can see,
but the computer may have some trouble seeing. If we can do that,
then we have the possibility to reconstruct all of the
substructures within a cell,
and that would be for the first time.
It's a very exciting challenge right now that a lot of
people are interested in trying to pursue. Now, another aspect
that makes this particularly challenging is that the microscope
itself, that is doing the ion beam milling
and scanning electron microscopy, frequently,
sort of,
it doesn't necessarily work smoothly through thousands and
thousands of slices.
And so again,
engineers are playing a very important role in making
sure that that microscope can run continuously for
weeks,
if not months,
which is what it takes to do an electron
microscope scan and then a slice with this ion beam. Essentially,
they have to be in coordination to go for weeks and
weeks at a time in order to slice through a
specimen.
So it's another example where lots of different
people from different fields-- engineers,
microscopists,
sample preparation-- is all playing an important role in
allowing this really new
approach for looking at cells at a very small
scale to be possible.